this constant of Cortez strike the word
thank you you know so many of our folks
across the aisle think that this is a
debate about whether we should be asking
who is a citizen or not in this country
the census is a constitutionally
mandated operation that we are required
to implement every 10 years it is one of
the most vital and sensitive things that
we do in our government any change to
the census any addition of a question
usually takes five years of a process to
make sure that it is vetted that every
word has been tested to make sure that
it is effective because it is one of the
most important things that we do so it's
not that I want to this is not about
whether or not I want to know who is a
citizen in the United States or not what
I want to know is why after why this
question was added why two years have
been shaved off of that five year
process I want to know why we have
skipped every normal mandated procedure
what in testing how this question gets
added in the census I want to know why
it was why this question was magically
added after we have seen that a
political operative new and detailed an
intent to intimidate racial and
immigrant communities for a partisan
purpose saying this will hurt Democrats
and help Republicans that's what I want
to know I want to know why Wilbur Ross
why secretary Ross continued to meet
with people of disturbing political
affiliations after his own
administration warned him to stop he
came right here and I asked him did you
continue speaking with him after this he
told me no we had an email and he did he
did I want to know why people like Chris
Kobach with a documented history of
overseeing effects he has a resume of
voter suppression techniques in the
state of Kansas I want to know why folks
like that have their fingerprints all
over the most sensitive census operation
that we have as a United States
government this determines who is here
this determines who has power in the
United States of America that is what we
want to know I want to know about
corruption that's what I want to know
about the racism that and the and the
very disturbing history that we're
seeing here that's what I want to know
and so we gave the opportunity to ask we
asked why are all of these things
happening why is all of this connected
why are there so many people everyone
from Steve Bannon to Kris Kobach having
their fingerprints and their political
intent all over the United States Census
why and what do we get nothing no
response stonewalling we're getting
obstruction we're getting a lack of
answers I don't want to issue a subpoena
nobody wants to be in a position where
you have to issue a subpoena of an
administration official because we are a
co-equal branch of government and it
should be expected that when we ask a
question we get a response but when we
don't we have to do our job
I never no one wants to be in a position
where we have to issue a subpoena but
today because of the secretary and
because of the Attorney General's
refusal to cooperate with a co-equal
branch of government we have no choice
this is about the rule of law this is
about the respect of our institutions
and this is about the power of all of us
as a body as United States Congress and
the integrity of the government of the
United States thank you very much I
yield the rest of my time to the chair
to the gentlelady thank you very much
for your comments when I became chairman
of this committee I made it very clear
that I took issue to issuance of
subpoenas very very very seriously I
don't know if you know it but in the
past we have had chairmen that have
literally put out hundreds of subpoenas
we've put out very very few and we've
been very very careful for the very
reasons you just stated we see it as a
very very serious matter and you're
absolutely right we
come to this point and we need to be
very clear this is this you're right we
this is our job and I would consider it
legislative malpractice if we don't do
our job we are not sworn to the
president we're not sworn to a party
whispering someone to the Constitution
and so I want to thank you for your
comments